hello and welcome to election social
from Sky News with BuzzFeed streamed
across the world online my name is Lewis
Connell political correspondent at Sky
News and tonight we're doing something a
little bit special the first election
night for the digital age never been
tried before at this scale so if it's a
bit rough around the edges bear with us
it's not supposed to be perfect but it
is going to be conversational fun but
with a very serious intent I am at
Daytona buzzer and I'm a social reporter
at BuzzFeed news but for tonight
you can regard me as the resident means
specialist and a lover of all things
internet culture night on the town or
Netflix and chill Netflix and chill I'm
rolling man thought Skye's technology
correspondent for the last six weeks
I've been diving into the digital war
for Downing Street we've made it through
a very long campaign to election night
we're going to bring you the key results
and we're gonna dissect the drama with
some very special guests
but don't worry it's not just me I'm not
like Macaulay Culkin I'm not home alone
a little bit earlier we asked you why do
more young people not vote than any
other age group you've been voting and
now the results written 22% of you said
it's laziness 37% said it's because they
don't understand politics 29% said
nobody to vote for and 12% said
something else all right we are going to
get very very close to that really
exciting exit poll you know you really
really are looking potentially at the
conservative landslide or something very
very close to it majority of 8686 for
Boris Johnson there which I don't think
many people were predicting how are you
feeling after that result that a quick
exit poll like obviously it's Christmas
for you believe it I mean when I saw the
result coming through I think I gave off
a massive chair yeah not control my
excitement but I do think you have to of
course take exit polls with a pinch of
salt of course of course
I think the margin of every means that
we will get a majority would it be that
big I'm not convinced but you know think
of sweet sweet sass of course you were
part of going for Corbin and hashtag
counsel the haters the campaign about
getting young people registered to vote
how are you feeling Addison um I think
when it comes to exit polls actually
saying we have to take you in a pinch of
salt I think that was always going to be
some sort of conservative majority that
was looming yeah well when the final
ballot comes in yeah I'll see what what
we're saying then but for now I still
got a favor we are thrilled that the man
himself
internet sensation mr. Michael Spicer is
here with us all night Michael I am
genuinely thrilled I am I'm a huge huge
huge fan you've made us three exclusive
films as I say when it comes to trust in
politics yeah Boris Johnson is basically
now on course for the biggest
conservative victory since 1987
surpassing Margaret Thatcher's victory
in 1979 he's gonna be a folk hero he's
already in conservative legend Thank You
Lewis and Emily it's been absolutely
riveting watching all the action unfold
but here we are back on the panel we've
got some new faces joining us politics
has never been so divided and the
language used both online and offline
has become in
recently toxic but how do you deal with
the trolls and is there any way to stop
it this not know a lot about that issue
we've got cryin fooi who is a
parliamentary assistant and part of the
hashtag let her stand campaign
Emily Hewitt CERN is a well-known
right-wing commentator every tomlinson
who's responsible for the Miller fandom
phenomenon and Molly Goodfellow a comedy
writer and meme queen thank you ladies
for joining me
so you're in Jeremy Corbyn constituency
or at least near it is his fault do we
think it's Jeremy Corbyn yeah do you
think boomers are responsible for any of
the problems that we face as a society
today probably because they are stuck in
their ways and they're very
black-and-white event things young
people work harder than your generation
do no no well easy yes we've left the
slightly stressful area where all our
bosses have congregated watching the
election very intensely setting down the
first draft of history is going and see
what our boys are up to no in fact I
know they're coming busy because they
because I'm talking to them here we go
I've been watching election social from
Sky News and BuzzFeed UK thanks for
watching this has been an experiment in
political programming for the digital
age an election night we hope you
enjoyed it we certainly enjoyed being
with you it's a whole new political
world out there let's see what happens
next
goodbye goodbye